Ready to go behind the scenes.
Hello world,
it's Saroj and let me show you how to
teach people artificial intelligence.
I'll go over three crucial concepts
in order, how to design a curriculum,
how to teach in real life, and how to
make an educational AI youtube video.
If you're new, click subscribe to
keep up with my latest AI content.
I've now been teaching people AI for
about two years full time on Youtube.
Every week I create as much
AI content as I possibly can.
Read me placed feedback and improve
it to be even better the next week.
Before you start writing curriculums,
you've got to start with the
most important first step.
Believe you can do this.
It's estimated that the human brain
has about 70,000 thoughts per day,
that 70 k opportunities to
program positive beliefs
about yourself or it could
be 70 k opportunities to reinforce
your same old self doubts.
If you believe you can't teach AI because
you don't have a degree or you're too
old or you're bad at math,
that will become your reality.
The mind responds to its
programming like a machine,
but the difference is that you have the
consciousness to choose what source code
you want to input.
Neither of my parents went to college,
they struggled financially
when I was growing up,
and I don't have any
graduate level degrees.
The reason I've been able to do
this is because I believed I could.
The Internet is your university. It's
your responsibility to use it. As such,
anyone can become an expert in this field
if they'd put in the time to study and
are motivated to push past the difficulty.
So onto designing an AI curriculum,
start by asking yourself four questions.
What's your topic?
Who are your students?
What do you want them to be able to do
and how will you measure their ability?
Teaching a curriculum
takes a lot of endurance,
so the best way to prevent burnout is
to pick a topic you're really passionate
about.
The topic you pick will also
depend on what stage you're in,
in your AI journey.
If you're just starting out,
it might be learning basic python for
machine learning or linear Algebra,
basics for machine learning.
If you're more advanced,
it could be modern day neural
architectures or reinforcement learning.
Spend some time alone to browse
the web and just brainstorm.
Find some cool AI demos. Read some
blog posts, watched some videos,
listen to some podcasts,
see what researchers are
talking about on Twitter.
Eventually you'll find a couple
of topics that excite you.
Pick the one that excites you the most
and don't worry if you don't understand
that topic completely.
Teaching is the best
way to learn anything.
Learn and teach as you go.
Now,
depending on the difficulty
level of your curriculum,
certain student populations
will be best suited for it.
Try to learn as much as you
can about your students.
Are they in university?
When was their last dental appointment?
What should you expect them to
know before the first lecture?
What problems do students
typically have with this material?
At this level,
there's very likely already
been curriculums created
that are somewhat similar
to your topic.
Find them on Google and see what kind
of prerequisites they ask of students.
What are students concerns and questions.
Usually forums and social media groups
are a treasure trove to learn about them.
The next question is what do you
want your students to be able to do?
It's supremely important to have goals
in mind when both studying and teaching
Ai.
This can be application specific,
like the ability to create a classifier
for health care or more broad like the
ability to read and understand
the math for deep learning.
It could also be the ability to take a
more advanced course or even get a job in
the field.
Try to answer these questions as
specifically as you can as it will give
structure to everything else.
Next,
how are you going to
measure students' abilities?
While some learning goals can be
achieved through listening to a lecture,
some might require active experimentation,
practice and discussion.
You might want to create quizzes
or group project assignments,
a midterm, a final, a
hackathon, a cage match.
There's a lot of possibilities.
I found several free learning management
system tools you can use to help you
create these easily.
There'll be in the video description
when it comes to designing the curriculum
itself.
You want to synthesize existing
curriculums and add in your own touch.
For example,
if we want to create a
curriculum on convolutional
neural networks will see that
both Coursera and Stanford
have courses on this topic.
They both have their merits.
The Coursera course seems more real world
application oriented while Stanford's
is more based on theory.
Coursera dives straight into CNN theory
while Stanford starts with feed forward
neural network theory then
moves on to comp nets.
Stanford also moves on to talk about newer
libraries like Pi Torch near the end.
While Coursera doesn't,
but neither of these courses mentioned
using convolutional networks on text
data,
which they've been shown to surprisingly
perform well on specifically regarding
sequence classification and while these
presenters are clearly credentialed,
their lectures are not as dense and
attention grabbing as they could be.
Just ask Carrie k.
H perhaps we could even add
our own section on ethics
applied to computer vision
or you have a more comprehensive history
of previous techniques in computer
vision.
It's important to develop some intuition
around the order of complexity of these
subtopics.
It looks like CNNs require
an understanding of several
topics including matrix
multiplication,
gradient based optimization,
and feed forward neural network theory,
different courses.
We'll tackle these
prerequisites in different ways.
Some will attempt to teach them all within
the course including programming and
some will require preexisting knowledge.
I've found it's the most fun to teach
all or almost all of the necessary
Prereq's within the confines of a
course and it's not over promising.
If you can actually deliver,
it will be more challenging,
but that's what makes this process so fun,
right?
There are tons of different ways
of ordering topics by complexity.
Maybe you want a deep learning library
first approach or a math first or an
application first approach,
whatever works for you.
I've also found hosting my curriculum on
get hub is a simple and easy way to get
developers on board.
Plus get hub allows endless edits and
collaborations on things you might've
missed out on, which students
have definitely helped me with.
Curriculums longer than 12 weeks are
really hard for me to stick to as my
interest wanes near the very end
and I want to start working on other
curriculums that might be a good upper
threshold and have a diverse set of
learning resources.
If you have too much broad content,
students may complain that it's not
detailed enough. If it's too deep,
students may complain that there's not
enough high level overview and real world
applicability. That's why having
both is the best path forward.
Now with your newly formed curriculum,
you're ready to start teaching AI.
If you're hosting a weekly meetup,
a university class of public school
class or an after school club,
you'll be teaching in person.
From what I've learned,
teaching at various venues in real life,
you need to be very engaging.
It's 2018 and people,
especially AI enthusiasts have no
patience for a boring lecturer.
What with all the engaging educational
creators popping up every week on social
media,
they also have their cell phones in their
pockets full of interesting things to
do.
What you can do in person that you can't
do in a video though is engage in real
time. Don't think of it like a
lecture, but more like a conversation.
Encourage your audience to interrupt you,
to ask questions,
to debate a point amongst themselves.
You can get feedback in real time
and give them a unique experience and
depending on your locale,
the audience will likely have a
shared set of cultural and or societal
experiences.
Leverage that relate your topics to things
your audience can relate to if you're
teaching AI and Carola,
for example,
mentioned ways AI can be used to help
with the flooding people are experiencing.
I love watching charisma on command.
There are some great techniques to learn
how to capture and keep an audience's
attention. You want to be strong
but humble, fun, but educational.
This doesn't come easy,
just like all things worth doing
and practice makes perfect. Now,
if you're like me and want to make
educational videos for your curriculum,
let me give you some
insights into my process.
I first choose a topic for a
video that I find interesting.
Then I spend time learning,
synthesizing blog posts,
videos, research papers, anything
I can find on that topic.
Once I feel prepared, I'll write a
script. I first introduced the topic,
give the history of it,
showed some real world applications,
discuss the mathematical theory,
then dive into the code,
followed by a discussion of
the demo and a conclusion.
I'll revise it once to correct
any spelling and ordering errors.
Then I'll add in some
humor on this second pass.
That's to keep it engaging
and give it my voice.
I'll then read my script
off a teleprompter.
You can find several online links,
will be in the video description.
I read my words from a teleprompter with
the green screen behind me and some led
lights on either side. I use a
sign Heizer globally or microphone,
a Canon DSLR camera.
Then once I have footage,
I'll transfer it over from
my SD card to my computer.
While I used to edit my videos myself
for a little over a year and a half,
I now have an editor helped me with this
final cut pro is what we use to edit
the footage. You'll first one to key
out yourself. Then add in a background,
add an images that help explain
what you're talking about.
I tend to look for memes
that are technical as they
are the best intersection of
engaging and educational.
If you want to take your
video to the next level,
you can use Adobe after effects to create
animations linked to a course on that
in the video description.
Then just export and upload to your
favorite social media platforms.
Share to your friends and relevant to
spread the AI power as far as you can.
It's okay to learn AI
by teaching it and yes,
creating a learning path for other people
and then following through with it is
hard work.
But if you believe in the power of AI
to solve some of the world's hardest
problems, it's worth every ounce
of effort. And that's Iraq.
It subscribed.
And I'll grant you three wishes and
make sure to connect with me on Twitter,
Instagram, and Facebook for more AI
content. For now, I've got to teach,
so thanks for watching.